what is the importance of playing here
in the city of Paris um well I mean I've
played in France many many times and
I've had very very good results I think
if I go back the first time I broke
2,700 was actually in France in 2008
when I played in the French league so I
have very good memories in general
playing in France
okay parties of course nice city it's
relatively close to Poland I guess well
I'm happy I'm here I have been applied
in to Romani parties before I hope I
will do my best
yeah it's a wonderful city to be in I
mean yeah also the tournament is great I
mean it all you got all the top players
and it's happening every year now and
I'm really thrilled to be part of it
again
yeah this year it's fantastic we moved
from Bhutan to the center and it's very
nice place like two minutes from shams
it is a it's very enjoyable well first
of all you don't really need an excuse
to like playing interests fantastic city
and I hope to do well I mean it's the
first rapid in blitz that I will play
and I hope to get off to a good start
obviously it's much more comfortable to
play when you have something to do
during your free time you have all those
museums you have a brilliant Cozine and
so on and yeah I don't think it can
really change my attitude to the games
but it obviously makes your free time
much more fun and pleasant is very
important for chess you do tournament
even in Toronto to tournament in Paris
and they where they have to play in
virus oh well it's now become a sort of
tradition for me every year I play here
and now it's actually much nicer because
we're in the center of the city of
course it is very important to do well
here especially since in Paris I don't
have a very good record the last few
years I haven't done well at all and a
my record in my for example st. Louis it
has been much better so
I mean I'm not superstitious but I I do
want to break the trend being being in
Paris being so close to the center or
the heart of it all here with the Arc de
Triomphe very close by it's just a very
nice feeling and summer in Europe
generally is pretty nice obviously this
year it's quite a bit hotter but just
playing playing in France and John one's
been really good to me it's always a
good feeling of course it's also very
nice that this year against the
tournament is open to the public I would
be able to interact with the audience
and - of course I'm very comfortable
riding very nearby and I just know the
surroundings
very very well